Always tell or ask your parents before you go further than your allowed play area.
Be careful when you talk to strangers.
Never give out your name, phone number, school, or home address...
...to someone you don't know.
Some people can be bad.
Never agree to eating anything from or going anywhere with strangers,...
...no matter how sweet they appear.
Say "no" if someone tries to touch you in a way that makes you uncomfortable.
And report to your teacher or parent or an older person at once.
Use the internet only when your parent or grown-up is around.
There can be stuff on the internet that can harm or hurt you.
Do not open unfamiliar websites.
You must know your contact numbers and address.
If you get lost in the store, call your parents from the counter.
Always trust your inner voice.
Back off from anything or person that doesn't make you feel good.